tenemos el siguiente problema en donde
tenemos que la glucosa que es de su
fórmula molecular c6 h 12 ó 6 reacciona
con el oxígeno para formar dióxido de
carbono que es co2 y agua que es h2o la
pregunta es la siguiente cuánta masa de
oxígeno en gramos estamos estamos
pidiendo en gramos se requieren para
completar la reacción de 25 gramos de
glucosa es decir inicialmente a nosotros
nos dan 25 gramos de glucosa de esta
fórmula se 6 h 12 ó 6 y nos preguntan
cuánta masa de oxígeno necesito para que
se lleve a cabo la reacción tenemos otra
parte de esta de este problema y nos
preguntan cuánta masa de dióxido de
carbono co2 y agua h2o se forman y esto
nos lo piden en gramos entonces como ya
recordarás este es nuevamente un
problema de este geometría que es un
problema de este geometría esencialmente
me dicen bueno yo te doy 25 gramos de
glück
ok y este que sabemos que reacciona con
este oxígeno forma co2 y h2o entonces
los problemas de éste kiómetros
esencialmente quieren responder cuánta
cantidad de oxígeno yo necesito para que
reaccione con estos 25 gramos de glucosa
y cuántos gramos de co2 y de h2o tendré
como productos al final de esta reacción
entonces como cualquier problema de este
geometría voy a tener que plantear
primero cómo es la ecuación entonces yo
voy a tener aquí que se 6 h 12
o 6 esta es la glucosa reacciona con el
oxígeno pero el oxígeno en su forma
molecular es o 2 ok entonces ahí
reacciona con el oxígeno y que me
produce me dice que produce co2 que es
dióxido de carbono y agua
entonces aquí ya tenemos la ecuación que
describe esta reacción la siguiente
parte es bueno ya tenemos cómo
reaccionan estos estos reactivos y aquí
cuáles son los productos que se generan
entonces la pregunta siguiente es bueno
esta ecuación ya está balanceada vamos a
ver entonces qué es lo cómo le hago para
balancear aquí aquí ahí les voy a dar
una recomendación y les voy a recomendar
que balance en primero las moléculas más
complicadas por ejemplo esta glucosa la
glucosa está muy complicada entonces
vamos a tratar de balancear primero ésta
recordemos que significa balancear que
el mismo número de átomos de cada
elemento que haya del lado izquierdo del
lado de los reactivos los haya del lado
derecho que es del lado de los productos
entonces por ejemplo aquí tenemos 6
átomos de carbono ok
6 átomos de carbono y son los únicos que
hay verdad ahora aquí el carbono se
encuentra solo en esta molécula y tengo
1 así que si multiplicamos esta molécula
por 6 ya te
y equilibrados o balanceados los
carbonos vámonos con el hidrógeno aquí
voy a tener 12 hidrógenos 12 hidrógenos
mientras que del lado derecho solo se
encuentran aquí en el agua y tengo 2
entonces para que yo tenga en total 12
hidrógenos vamos a multiplicar esta
molécula por 6 entonces ya tendremos 6
por 2 que son 12 hidrógenos y ya están
equilibrados con los del lado izquierdo
ahora vámonos con los oxígenos aquí del
lado izquierdo aquí tengo 6 y aquí tengo
6 moléculas y en cada una tengo 2 así
que tengo 12 también aquí tengo sólo 6
moles 66 átomos 6 átomos de oxígeno
verdad uno por cada molécula de agua
entonces como deben ser la misma
cantidad de ambos lados aquí ya tengo
seis aquí necesitaría yo 12 12 digo
podría multiplicar aquí en la cantidad
de glucosa pero si yo cambio la cantidad
de glucosa
que reordenar o cambiar la cantidad de
todo lo que ya tenía así que lo más
sencillo es cambiar el número de
oxígenos que necesito entonces yo
necesito 12 y aquí tengo 2 pues basta
con que yo saque 6 de estos muy bien
entonces ya está balanceada la ecuación
tenemos 6 6 carbonos del lado izquierdo
6 carbonos del lado derecho
12 hidrógenos y aquí tengo 12 hidrógenos
y aquí tengo 6 y 12 son 18 oxígenos y
aquí tengo 12 y 6 son 18 oxígenos
entonces ya estamos muy bien balanceados
ahora vamos con la siguiente parte ya
vamos a realmente resolver el problema
vamos a ver qué nos dan 25 gramos de
glucosa 25 gramos de glucosa
de glucosa
muy bien entonces primero lo que tenemos
que usar son las proporciones este
kilométricas que significa eso que la
cantidad de moles se va preservando es
decir si aquí yo utilizo
la proporción si aquí yo tengo un molde
glucosa y reacciona con 6 de oxígeno si
yo tengo otra cantidad de moles de esta
glucosa en realidad va a reaccionar de
forma proporcional con una cantidad de
moles de oxígeno vamos a seguir haciendo
esto es esencialmente lo que hicimos en
el último vídeo y vamos a tener que
calcular el peso atómico o la masa
atómica de la glucosa y para eso vamos a
utilizar una tabla periódica ésta está
en inglés pero es una que encontré en
wikimedia commons y está hecha por le
van hand cedric
que está el nombre de quien la realizó
le van hand cedric y bueno pues vamos
vamos de lleno a resolver el problema
esencialmente que necesitamos para
calcular la masa atómica de la glucosa
pues a ver la masa del carbono del
hidrógeno y del oxígeno así que vámonos
con el carbono
por aquí ante el carbono de genes lo
marcó bien esta es la masa atómica del
carbono 12 puntos 0 11
con este entonces que tenemos del carbón
o del carbón o vamos a describirlo solo
como carbón este pesa tiene una masa
atómica de 12
12.01 ce quien más quien más necesitamos
del oxígeno aquí está el oxígeno déjeme
lo marcó con amarillito que es tiene una
masa atómica de 15.999 que hay algunas
personas ya lo dejan como 16 pero vamos
a dejarlo así que tiene el oxígeno tiene
una masa atómica de 15.999
ponerle gramos ok y quien me falta el
hidrógeno el hidrógeno donde está el
hidrógeno bueno es que hay que recorrer
nos hacia la izquierda es el primer
elemento de la tabla periódica aquí está
en la en la esquina y tiene una masa de
1.007 9 ok vamos a dejarlo con 1.007 9
regresa aquí entonces el hidrógeno
el hidrógeno tiene una masa de 1 punto
pero eran 20 es verdad 00 79 gramos muy
bien ya que tenemos esto pues ahora sí
vamos a calcular cuál es la masa atómica
o la masa molecular de la glucosa ok
cuál es la masa de la glucosa vamos a
ver tengo yo sé 6 h 12 o 6
vamos a ver entonces esencialmente lo
que tengo que hacer es sumar la masa
atómica de cada uno de los elementos
entonces por ejemplo cada átomo de
carbono tiene una masa de 12.0 11 que
déjenme de una vez ponerlo ya el rol
redondeado y ponerlo con este color esto
vamos a dejarlo en 12 para que sea más
fácil esto en 16 y esto vamos a dejarlo
en 1 sale ya está
redondeado entonces cuál es la masa de
la glucosa tengo 6 átomos de carbono y
cada uno pesa 12 entonces tengo 6 por 12
más tengo que sumar 12 de hidrógeno que
pesa cada uno un gramo y 6 átomos de
oxígeno y cada oxígeno pesa 16 entonces
esto que nos da esto va a ser igual a 6
por 12 son 72 más 12 por 1 que sólo son
12 más 6 por 16 6 por 10 son 66 por 6
son 36 así que son 60 más 36 son 96 muy
bien y finalmente cuánto es esto bueno
vamos a ver son vamos a ver cuánto es
esto saquemos la calculadora y entonces
tengo 72 más 12
96 y esto nos da 180
estos son 180 180 gramos ok
muy bien entonces cada mol de glucosa
tiene una masa de 180 gramos unos
tantito abajo entonces recurramos a esto
vamos a hacer el cambio porque
necesitamos saber cuántos moles de
glucosa tenemos no cuántos gramos
así que si yo tengo 25 gramos 25 gramos
de glucosa
así de
c 6 h 12 o 6 y esto yo lo voy a
multiplicar por un 1 adecuado es decir
vamos a tener hacer el cambio de
unidades yo voy a tener que dividir aquí
entre gramos de c 6 h 12 o 6 para que de
esta forma estas unidades se cancelen y
aquí arriba voy a tener moles tengo
moles de ese 6 h 12 o 6
voy a multiplicar por este número
entonces qué es lo que tengo que poner
aquí por cada mol de glucosa cuántos
gramos tengo tengo 180 gramos entonces
la ventaja que tenemos ya con esto es
que los gramos de glucosa se cancelan y
simplemente esto me queda como 25 sobre
180 y las unidades que me restan son
moles de ese 6 16 h 12 ó 6 ok entonces
tengo 25 sobre 180 moles 16h 12 ó 6
recordemos que un molde un mol
es este el número de aboga de avogadro
que tiene un número de avogadro de
moléculas un número de avogadro son 6
puntos 0 20 algo por 10 a la 23
moléculas correcto un numerito cercano a
eso entonces vamos a ver cuánto es esto
esto es 25
5 sobre 180
esto que me da punto 13 88
voy a dejarlo en puntos 0.13 9
entonces estos son 0.13 9 moles de
glucosa puede escribir lo mejor así
glucosa perfecto ahora el detalle es que
nos nos preguntan cuánta cuánto oxígeno
necesitamos para que esta reacción se
lleve a cabo entonces sabemos que esta
proporción se conserva es decir si yo
multiplico por por ejemplo
por algún uno
en este caso otra vez para que yo pueda
cancelar las unidades de mol de glucosa
pues aquí abajo pongo mol de glucosa
ok de glucosa y arriba debo poner algo
las proporciones se conservan entonces
voy a poner los moles de
o dos o dos y vamos a ponerle requerido
déjenme ponerlo con otro color
moles
de todos requerido entonces qué es lo
que tenemos cada por cada modo por cada
uno de estos moles de glucosa yo
necesito 6 de oxígeno y entonces ya
quedamos verdad porque lo que podemos
hacer es cancelar otra vez estos muebles
de glucosa y simplemente me queda punto
139 por 6.139 por 6 vamos a ver qué es
eso ahí tengo punto 139 esencialmente
vamos a multiplicar esto por 6 y lo que
me da es punto 83 33 33 vamos a dejarlo
en punto 8 33 entonces estos son 0.8 33
moles de oxígeno requerido perfecto ya
tenemos la cantidad de moles ahora sí
vamos a ver cuántos gramos de oxígeno es
lo que realmente tenemos
bajar un poquito tengo
misma técnica verdad 0.8 33 moles de
oxígeno ok
requeridos vamos a ponerle y vamos a
multiplicar otra vez por un 1 adecuado
por queremos cancelar los moles verdad
entonces un mol
de todos requerido y arriba tenemos que
poner la que queremos gramos de co2
requerido pero no sabemos cuánto tiene
de masa y un molde de oxígeno molecular
es decir dos átomos de oxígeno entonces
vamos a calcular eso si cada uno de
estos pesa 16 entonces el o2 tiene un
peso tiene un peso de 2 por 16 2 veces
16 que son 32 gramos ok eso es
esencialmente fue fácil de khan de
calcular tengo 32 gramos entonces por
cada molde oxígeno yo voy a tener 32
gramos y otra vez los moles de oxígeno
requeridos se cancelan y sólo me queda
que esto va a ser déjenme ver esto es
simplemente vamos a sacar la calculadora
a esta punto 8 3 3 y esto lo
multiplicamos por 32 y eso nos da 26.666
vamos a dejarlo en 26.7 ya redondeado
entonces estos son 26.7 gramos de
oxígeno requerido y ya tenemos resuelta
la primera pregunta nos preguntaban que
cuántos gramos de oxígeno se necesitaban
pues ya tenemos que son 26.7 gramos de
este oxígeno perfecto vamos con la
siguiente pregunta la segunda pregunta
nos nos decían cuánta masa de dióxido de
carbono co2 y de agua h2o gramos se
forman
cuando se forma entonces vamos a hacer
esencialmente lo mismo tomemos aquí ya
habíamos obtenido la cantidad de moles
de glucosa que tiene la reacción
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es ahora
usar la misma proporciones tequio
métrica para el los moles de de co2 que
entonces tengo otra vez 0.139 moles de
glucosa y vamos a multiplicar vamos a
multiplicar por esta proporción es decir
yo quiero ver cuántos moles de glucosa
están relacionados con los moles
co2
ok entonces regresemos a mi reacción
original y tengo que por cada molde
glucosa tengo 6 de co2
entonces por cada uno de estos tengo
seis moles de co2 nuevamente estos yo
los puedo cancelar y lo que me queda es
simplemente seis veces punto 139 y me va
a quedar en moles de co2 vamos a ver eso
cuánto es esto esencialmente ya lo
habíamos calculado verdad son es la
misma proporción que había con el
oxígeno miren aquí tenía por cada molde
glucosa tengo 6 de oxígeno también tengo
6 de co2 así que este va a ser el mismo
resultado van a ser 0.8 33 moles moles
de co2 perfecto entonces realmente no
tuvimos que repetir los cálculos es
esencialmente las mismas proporciones y
si nos damos cuenta vamos a tener las
mismas proporciones de agua porque
también tenemos 6 moles de agua en este
en este problema
vamos a ver
se repite con todos entonces realmente
no tengo que hacer muchos cálculos
porque son son los mismos muy bien
entonces aquí lo que vamos a tener
también es que son 0.8 33 moles de agua
ahí está ok ahora bien ya vámonos a la
recta final de este problema porque sólo
necesitamos calcular el peso de cada de
co2 de esta cantidad de moles de co2 y
del agua entonces primero veamos quién
es o cuál es la masa de co2
creo que este color no está bien vamos a
tomar este
entonces tenemos co2 cuánto pesa que
massa tiene bueno es uno de carbono o de
carbón que son 12 y 2 de oxígeno
entonces cada uno de carbono pesa 12 y
tenemos 2 de oxígeno que cada uno pesa
estos son 12 más 32 que son son son 54
perdón son 44 44 gramos de co2 ok
entonces si esto es lo que pesa vamos a
hacer la conversión de moles
gramos porque yo tengo otra vez 0.8 33
moles de co2 vamos a multiplicar por un
1 adecuado que en este caso podemos
multiplicar
diciendo que por cada molt de co2
yo tengo 44 gramos de co2 entonces de
esta forma otra vez cancelamos esto y
simplemente es 44 por punto 8 33
44 por 0.8 33 y eso nos da 36.65 voy a
dejarlo en 36.7
36.7
gramos quedan los gramos de co2 perfecto
ahora vamos a hacer el cambio el cambio
al agua entonces vamos a ver el agua el
agua tiene dos átomos de hidrógeno y
cada uno pesa uno y tiene un átomo de
oxígeno y cada uno pesa 16 cuántos
gramos tuvo esto pues 16 más 2 son 18
gramos si yo tengo 18 gramos por cada
mol hagamos nuevamente nuestra
conversión entonces yo tengo
0.8 33 moles de h2o y vamos a
multiplicar por este 1
por este numerito donde abajo tengo que
por cada mol de h2o estos van a ser 18
gramos de h2o entonces cancelamos los
moles y simplemente me quedan 18 por
punto 8 33 18 por 0.8 33 y esto nos da
14.99 4 vamos ya a resumir lo mejor en
15 entonces estos son 15
punto 0 gramos de h2o requeridos y ya
hemos terminado verdad ya tenemos que si
inicialmente teníamos 25 gramos de
glucosa entonces después obtuvimos que
vamos a necesitar y cuántos gramos aquí
está 26 puntos 7 gramos de oxígeno para
que se lleve a cabo esta reacción y
concluimos que vamos a obtener 36 puntos
7 gramos de dióxido de carbono y además
voy a ponerlo con otro color 15 gramos
de agua con esto terminamos